as mathematicians our approach is to
think hard about the problems who are
trying to solve and figure out the best
algorithms that we know for solving them
so if I wasn't before then I firmly
became an algorithmic number theorist
when I came into cryptography you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen Hughes Inga from ancient
hieroglyphics to secret decoder rings to
world war ii enigma code makers and code
breakers cryptography has always held a
particular fascination for us but few of
us have the skills or can actually do
the math to unlock the mysteries of
encrypted data fortunately dr. Kristen
Lauder distinguished mathematician
founder of the women in numbers Network
and principal researcher and research
manager for the cryptography group at
Microsoft Research can and she's using
her powers for good not for evil today
dr. Lauder tells us why she feels lucky
to do math for a living explains the
singular beauty of elliptic curves and
the singular difficulty of super
singular I saw Genie graphs talks about
how homomorphic encryption part of the
field of private AI allows us to operate
on while still protecting our most
sensitive data and shares her dream of
one day seeing a Grace Hopper light
conference to celebrate women in
mathematics that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
kristan Lauder welcome to the podcast
today it's great to have you with us
thank you so much nice to be here so
you're a principal researcher and the
research manager for the cryptography
group at Microsoft Research where you
apply number theory and algebraic
geometry to cryptography that's right
well I'm one of the lucky ones to have
such a great job to be able to spend my
life researching the things that I love
so I was very lucky to find the
opportunity to come to Microsoft and
apply the mathematics that I learned in
graduate school and worked on as an
assistant professor at the University of
Michigan to work in the exciting area of
cryptography so tell us a little bit
more about the general field of
cryptography we've got mostly high tech
listeners who are probably familiar a
bit but I think there's room for a
little bit of a overview of the field
what is cryptography about and why is it
important so cryptography is essential
in today's economy for securing our
e-commerce and our cloud and all of our
online presence and interactions so the
tools that cryptography provides are for
encryption which provides
confidentiality for data while it's
being stored or transmitted but also
authentication so that you know when
you're interacting with a party online
that they're actually the party that
they say that they are so you're
actually buying something from the
vendor that you think you're buying from
rather than from somebody else so
there's a whole infrastructure around
cryptography that we use in industry and
government that's very important for
securing our interactions so it's all
about being able to share information
and not have somebody that shouldn't
have that information get it that's
right so public key cryptography is the
science of interacting publicly and
ending up with something that secret so
the exciting thing for me is is that
number theory is basically the
foundation for public key cryptography
so the way public key cryptography works
is is that there's hard number theory
problems that are used as the basis of
secure
for these public key interactions so
that includes key exchange encryption
digital signatures so let's talk about
your specific work right now and you're
known for several things in the field
and one of them is elliptic curve
cryptography so what is it why is it
important and how has it impacted the
field well I was very excited when I
came to Microsoft to work on elliptic
curve cryptography it had been proposed
around 1985 but it was not yet being
used widespread in the industry in 1999
when I came to Microsoft and I worked
for my first about five years here on
kind of evangelizing the technology and
working with another researcher in my
team Peter Montgomery to develop our
elliptic curve cryptography code and to
optimize things and to make it work for
different platforms and that was a very
exciting entree for me into the industry
because I got to learn through
interacting with product groups so what
was really needed and how things work
and I got to work on real-world problems
that had a very real mathematical bent
so I got to go to the office of top
executives and have them freak out when
they found out that we're having a
meeting on an elliptic curve
cryptography and I got to you know file
patents where I was explaining elliptic
curve technology to lawyers who were
listening intently and trying to
understand so it was really fun can you
take a minute to explain it to our
audience sure so elliptic curves are a
very beautiful object which have been
studied in mathematics for more than a
hundred years they're actually a curve
so they have a geometric aspect to them
they have a shape in some sense but they
also have a group structure an algebraic
structure that allows you to take two
points on the curve and add them
together and it's this group structure
that you need and use in cryptography to
create these public key cryptosystems
now I understand it just slightly better
than I did one of the other things
you're known for is your work in super
singular I saw any graphs tell us the
story about how you came to introduce it
as a hard problem in cryptography well
that was a really lucky and
coincidence with some collaborators
postdoc and a visiting researcher that
were here at Microsoft Research with me
we were working on even a more
complicated object to higher dimensional
version of super singular I saw Genie
graphs and this was in 2005 and there
was a lot of hype around the nist hash
function competition so md5 had been
broken and it was clear that there was
going to be a new hash function selected
and so there were a lot of ideas kind of
swirling in the air and we were working
on these objects and realized wow
walking around on super singular
isogenic graphs could potentially be a
really hard problem and just because it
was new and that's what we do or
mathematicians we think about
cryptographic problems and how hard they
are proposing new ones attacking current
ones improving algorithms we thought oh
well since we can't figure out any way
to break it why don't we propose this as
a hard problem and we proposed a hash
function to go along with it and
presented it at the nist hash function
competition so it was really fun to find
out just a few years ago that interest
in this proposal has resurfaced because
of the current post quantum cryptography
competition where we need all kinds of
new ideas from mathematics to create new
crypto systems for which we don't
currently know polynomial time quantum
algorithms and since this was a new
system that we had proposed and no one
has come up with polynomial time quantum
algorithms yet it's under serious
consideration for Standardization as a
post quantum technology
[Music]
so let's talk a little bit about what I
think is like the most interesting thing
in your career right now and that's
homomorphic encryption it's a pretty big
deal for a lot of reasons tell us what
it is what's different about it and why
it's important in an AI world so
homomorphic encryption allows us to
compute unencrypted data so this is a
very important breakthrough standardized
crypto today that's in widespread use
such as block ciphers like AES or other
types of ciphers like stream ciphers if
you take two encrypted texts and kind of
try to operate on them add them together
or do something with them
you'll get just gibberish so home Orphic
encryption preserves the mathematical
structure underlying the cipher texts
and that allows us to actually operate
on them as mathematicians we can think
of cypher Texas just being these
mathematical objects and we can do
operations that correspond to circuits
which is how computers you know compute
on information and we can make it so
that you can do things like machine
learning algorithms doing predictions
and training models and doing all kinds
of exciting things to allow what we call
private AI unpack that a bit more
private AI is an interesting term and I
think it's super important in an AI
world and the largeness of what we're
doing with machine learning how does
that private AI come into play
well the AI world that we're living in
we're collecting more and more data and
we're improving our ability and our
algorithms for processing that data but
as we do that we're putting our privacy
at risk in the sense that there could be
very sensitive data being collected for
example our health information genomic
information financial information
private AI is a set of tools which can
be used to handle data in a private way
and yet still provide
services on top of it so you're able to
compute and operate on encrypted data
that's exactly right so for example for
the first time we can collect encrypted
information from a customer and they may
want to learn from that data in some way
get some business intelligence or get
some prediction and what we can do with
homomorphic encryption is we can handle
those computations in encrypted form so
the client or the customer can encrypt
their data and keep their key and never
share their key with us but share the
encrypted data with us and ask for some
prediction and then we can give them
this prediction by operating on their
encrypted data and what we're doing is
we're giving them an encrypted
prediction so we don't learn their data
or their prediction and then we return
it to them and they can use their key to
decrypt it so the information is never
decrypted while we have access to it
that just seems wild to me even trying
to wrap my brain around how that could
happen I'm impressed by you people
that's incredible well that's the
reaction that we get from a lot of
customers and potential partners that we
talk to that it's somehow a magic box
but from a mathematical perspective it's
very natural what you've done is you've
put the information into a structured
mathematical form and then you're
operating on it and as long as you do it
in a way that preserves that structure
of that data to begin with as you
operate on it you continue to preserve
that structure and it's just mathematics
and that's the beauty of mathematics it
is it's a beautiful thing let's drill in
on a couple of homomorphic stories as
you called them the other day these must
be the kind of stories mathematicians
tell their kids that bedtime you framed
one of the stories about health care and
genomic privacy and you called it one of
the most motivating things in your whole
career so tell us about that well
another lucky coincidence in my career
was that as we started to make
homomorphic encryption more practical
there was a genomics researcher here at
Microsoft Research David Hackerman and
said hey I bet you can do genomic
predictions using your technology and so
we work together with him in his group
to show doing live
make predictions using homomorphic
encryption and based on that I started
getting invited to a whole series of
meetings that I would never have gone to
otherwise biological data science at
Cold Spring Harbor for example where I
met the eye - organizers who are funded
by NIH to run the secure genome analysis
contest so I got involved in a whole
community of people in bioinformatics
and biostatistics that are interested in
protecting genomic data for the patients
for the future and this is something
that I found just really inspiring to be
working on something such as health and
genomic privacy which I feel is so
important for society and for which we
have mathematical tools that can be
helpful right so tell me this story
about AI - and how that all played out
with this homomorphic encryption so when
I first met the eye - organizers it was
at the Cold Spring Harbor meeting and I
was doing a tutorial on homomorphic
encryption and talking about some of the
sample tasks we'd been able to show were
possible with our practical home Orphic
encryption techniques and those included
at a distance and chi-squared statistics
and so when they ran their secure genome
analysis contest the first year they
picked those as some of the tasks and we
actually won the Edit distance tract of
that competition and I used to joke that
it was really funny because we had an
unfair advantage since they picked a
task we had already been working on but
we developed a really great relationship
with the I - organizers and the rest of
the community it's an international
community of teams from industry and
academia who worked to solve these
challenges each year and then come
together in a workshop to share each
other's solutions and the powerful thing
about this model for advancing the state
of the art is that okay we call it a
competition but that's a little bit
beside the point the point is really to
work collaboratively on these challenges
in a fixed timeframe and to produce
results which can provide benchmarks
that show how possible certain tasks are
with homomorphic encryption today
I love that in fact my brain is just
going a thousand directions right now
everything you say gives me another
question in my mind how else is this
playing out the homomorphic encryption
does that have other applications that
you could think would be interesting
research threads for people absolutely
so I like to say when I talk about
genomic privacy that it's an area where
we absolutely need that
interdisciplinary work to make progress
so we're working together we're
mathematicians computer scientists
working with machine learning
researchers biostatisticians even
medical practitioners and engineers and
policy makers to bring this all together
to provide solutions so that's a very
exciting area to be working in now
[Music]
so you said in a talk several years ago
my vision of the future I'm quoting you
my vision of the future is that all data
would be stored in the cloud in
encrypted form and then you kind of
laughed and admitted that there were
some problems with cryptographic cloud
storage so where are we now fast forward
several years do you remember saying
that yes and I'm still working towards
that vision I still believe in it so I
believe that well first of all we
already know today that encryption is a
very important technology for protecting
people's data and we like to say that
you can protect data in transit at rest
and while you're trying to compute on it
and the standardized cryptography that
we use today can help you protect the
data while it's being stored and what
homomorphic encryption can do is to help
you protect it in encrypted form but
still retain the utility of the data and
be able to compute on it right so I'm
still working toward that vision I
believe in it I believe we're gonna get
there what are your biggest challenges
to getting there
well homomorphic encryption is a
relatively new technology in the sense
that it's only ten years old
so that might sound like it's in Stone
Age when we think of how fast technology
evolves these days but typically for
public key cryptosystems over the last
4050 years there have been roughly at
least a ten year time lag before crypto
technologies get adopted and that's
because the community needs to have time
to think about how hard these problems
are and to set the security levels
appropriately right and to standardize
the technologies so we're just getting
to that point now we're kind of almost
ten years after the first solutions were
introduced we've put together a broad
coalition of researchers in industry
government and academia to come together
to try to standardize this technology
and we're having our second workshop in
March at MIT where we're going to try to
get broad approval for our standard
document which recommends security
parameters so that's the first challenge
is getting everyone to agree on what is
the strength of these systems kind of
essentially how hard are
these mathematical problems underneath
and then we plan to continue to build on
that with this community to get
agreement on a common set of api's for
example for how we can deploy this
technology in the industry and have
systems be interoperable and to work on
a rich set of applications with the
applications community that's really
important
getting the standards in place and then
moving forward as a group rather than
just a bunch of individual agents that's
right and it also helps to build the
public trust in the technology yeah and
that brings up a question in my mind
with the exponential growth of
technological devices and abilities do
new things sort of show up on your
doorstep in the encryption world and you
say oh got to think of that I mean how
much does the onward push of Technology
impact what you're trying to work on in
terms of standardizing and getting a lid
on it so there's always kind of new
events that come in that can be
disruptive but as mathematicians our
approach is to think hard about the
problems who are trying to solve and
figure out the best algorithms that we
know for solving them so if I wasn't
before then I firmly became an
algorithmic number theorist when I came
into cryptography and what we do is we
try to estimate the running time for the
algorithms that will break the crypto
systems were proposing and then we see
for example how these algorithms evolve
over time how much we can improve them
in different ways and we estimate the
running times for the future security of
these systems and so even though there
can be disruptive events that come in
when we have a community of
mathematicians working on these problems
over time we think we understand
relatively well what their security will
be in the future at least say ten
fifteen years into the future beyond
that so you're a mathematician first and
you've got an amazing CV and are truly
an inspiration in fact I've actually
been told you have fans like people find
out you're gonna be someplace and they
say I'm going to that
so talk about how you caught the math
bug and how it's affected your own life
well I loved math from a very early age
so I used to do math problems in the car
with my dad when I was young so story
problems and I just loved it and I guess
it was always very clear to me that that
was something that was fun and that I
was apparently good at so I was allowed
to work ahead in school on my own and I
just kind of zoomed through the
curriculum and I graduated from high
school when I was 15 and I went to the
University of Chicago so I was very
lucky to get into their undergraduate
program and then to be encouraged to go
to graduate school there so as a career
I have found that it has much more
importance and applications than what
people realize the mathematical
community is people sometimes don't
realize that their kids can go into math
and have a fabulous career in industry
and all kinds of areas and so I try to
spread that message as well and I
imagine that there's a lot of new
applications career-wise for mathematics
now even then there were 10 years ago
given what's going on in the high tech
world yeah so there are a lot of areas
where kind of math is underappreciated
because it's not called by that name for
example machine learning machine
learning is the foundation of AI machine
learning is just mathematics by it's
mostly computer scientists that are
doing it these days and so I'm in an
interesting position being a
mathematician working in the computer
science research lab because I have
access to great researchers on both
sides and it's really fun to see but it
can sometimes be frustrating to see the
lack of communication or crossover
between the fields yeah in fact even as
I think about it I'm not sure how big
the overlap is between computer science
and math because you'd think if you go
into computer science is heavily
mathematics based but if you're a
mathematician you're not necessarily a
computer scientist absolutely and even
as an undergraduate at the University of
Chicago I was struck by the fact that
some of the interesting mathematics was
actually being picked
and taught in the computer science
department because they realized even at
that time which was many years ago now
in the 80s that this mathematics was
very important was the foundation for
things like cryptography which computer
science students study and so they were
teaching this interesting mathematics in
the computer science department which
was frustrating to me because I said hey
we should be teaching this
undergraduates in math departments and I
still feel that way I still feel we
should be doing more cryptography in
math departments we should be doing more
machine learning more these are fun
areas that students love to learn
they're very motivating for students
[Music]
tell us about your involvement as a
fellow in the Association for women in
mathematics in your work as a co-founder
and women in numbers Network well I will
not lie to you there's still a lot of
challenges for women to face in science
in our society and in particular in
mathematics and computer science and I
found that creating the women in numbers
Network which is a research network for
women in number theory gave me a huge
boost in my career what we did was to
bring together all of the kind of
leading women that we knew in number
theory and asked them to kind of work
together with us to design research
projects that students and postdocs
could come and work on collaboratively
at a conference so that was our first
conference in 2008 called the wind
conference and we built on it from there
to build up the wind Network and the
wind network consists of now more than
200 women in number theory and we have
regular conferences we publish volumes
of research papers so we've published
around 50 research papers in number
theory each paper written by a group of
women number theorists anywhere from
four to seven number theorists and this
has been a really fun environment to get
involved in because as the young women
come into this network and see that they
can contribute and that they're valued
they get inspired and they start to help
lead the effort and organize the
conferences and so we now have kind of a
whole generation of women in wind that
work together to support each other and
do research together and have fun
together so how is that then reaching
out to say the next generation of women
in mathematics or number theory or
computer science do you have any
evangelical efforts for your
organization absolutely so what happened
for me is is that when I saw the
excitement that this model generated we
call it the wind model I thought this is
too good to be true we need to spread
this model to other areas of mathematics
because for decades we've had pipeline
issues
and kind of the leaky pipeline issue of
women leaving the profession at
different stages and so we still have
somewhere between five to ten percent
women faculty at the top research
universities and that's a number that is
way too low when I visit math
departments today I like to say 30%
that's the number you're shooting for
get to 30% female faculty and from there
you can get to 50% because of course we
should be at 50/50 and we find that when
we have more women faculty that that
encourages more women students as well
but the wind model was obviously a
powerful tool for advancing this vision
and so what I did was I decided to get
involved in the awm the Association for
women in mathematics which is an almost
50 year old professional Society Wow
with somewhere around 5,000 members and
to try to bring this idea in this model
into the awm and I became president of
the organization and during that time we
got an NSF grant for seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars to spread this
model to the other areas and now we're
in year three of the grant and so far
we've created almost 20 research
networks for women Wow in mathematics so
the other networks are not as old as
when so they don't have as many
researchers but each of those networks
probably has at least around 50 women
researchers in their area so that
represents a huge boost for women in
research in math is this international
or is it in the United States or how
does it spread globally it is
international for example for when we
have a whole nother series of
conferences called wine which is women
in numbers in Europe and I particularly
like that acronym well I'm going I'm not
even in numbers but I like it's fun and
so there's a series of wind conferences
in Europe but in each of these networks
for example women and topology is co
organized by a woman in Europe there's a
number of people from around the world
that both attend and take part in these
research conferences that also help to
organize them so Kristen grace hopper is
a conference that's for women and
technology how is it impacting the field
for
in general and what else can you tell us
about what we might be thinking for the
future of women in technology what I
really like about Grace Hopper is it
helps to celebrate the achievements of
women in computer science it helps to
generate excitement and confidence for
younger women in the field and it serves
as a recruiting platform for high tech
to attract the top talent in computer
science so what I really wish is that we
had a Grace Hopper conference for women
in mathematics as well and so hopefully
we'll get there but that pipeline is so
important that at the undergraduate
level we've got so much talent and young
women going into science and we just
need to support them and motivate them
to continue in the field and show that
there are a great career paths where
they can really make a difference and
have an impact in the world so maybe
it'll be the Kristin Lauder conference I
think that Grace Hopper is a great
achievement and I hope that we can
spread that model to other fields I love
this so much so much so tell me what
brought you to Microsoft Research and
why might others in your field want to
come here when I first came to Microsoft
I couldn't believe how great the
research environment was everybody had
their doors open and people actually
cared about what I worked on so when I
had my first meeting where I had to
explain elliptic curve cryptography to
lawyers and they had a video camera set
up and they were videotaping me I said
I've got to have it this is what I want
to do but I also really like the
interdisciplinary nature of it clearly
coming from a math background and
working with computer scientists was
very exciting but also the opportunity
to have a real world impact so to talk
to our product teams to talk to
customers to learn what their problems
are and how we can help solve them has
been a really exciting and rewarding
aspect of my career here what would you
say to aspiring researchers especially
to women who might want to get into this
field and
take up the research baton and run with
it I would say I think it's a very
rewarding career and coming to Microsoft
Research as for example an intern or a
visitor is a great way to kind of get
your foot in the door and test the
waters you can see if you like the kind
of fast pace collaborative environment
and my experiences that most interns
that come to my group in the summer the
answer is yes they love it they're more
productive than when they're just
working by themselves and they're
inspired by the challenging problems and
seeing all the great people around them
doing great research yeah so it's
obvious what gets you up in the morning
is there anything that keeps you up at
night in your field because I mean
there's a lot of things to keep us up at
night
nothing really keeps me I keep other
people up in there yeah I would say that
I'm particularly motivated to help make
change for women in society and in
science I think that there's a great
place for women to help us solve our
challenges in science and I'm
particularly disturbed by the low
numbers that we still see for women in
scientific career so that's the problem
I'd like to solve that's a good problem
to solve
Kristin Lauder thank you so much for
sharing your passion with us and taking
time out of your schedule to come be on
the podcast today thank you it's a great
pleasure talking with this
[Applause]
to learn more about dr. Kristen waters
and the not so secret world of computer
cryptography visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]